bei uns im Studio ist jetzt Heiko
techarts Chef der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft und zuständig für
die Bundespolizei schon guten Morgen
Herr Tigers also wenn wir uns jetzt noch
mal diese ja wirklich tragischen Bilder
anschauen aus diesem Transporter Kinder
Flüchtlinge die da übereinander
gefährlich liegen solche Bilder haben
wir schon mal gesehen da werden böse
Erinnerungen wach überrascht sie das
noch so tragisches ist überrascht mich
natürlich nicht wir haben ja auch schon
vor Monaten Frau Ministerin davor
gewarnt dass wir uns in eine neue
flüchtlingskrise bewegen wir stecken
mittendrin und aus der Matz wurde ja
deutlich die Kommunen haben im Moment
das Problem die ganzen Menschen
unterzubringen und das was der was der
Bürgermeister dort erzählte dass es
bittere Realität und das wird
wahrscheinlich auch noch verschärft
werden weil immer mehr Menschen zu uns
kommen also der der Flüchtlingsstrom
reist definitiv nicht ab was ist die
mehrere Realität ihrer Kollegen was
erzählen die Ihnen aus ihrem Alltag also
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben das
Riesenproblem dass die im Moment im
Rahmen einer Rasterfahndung eingesetzt
sind an der tschechischen Grenze also
dorthin hat sich momentan so die der der
Hauptschwerpunkt gebildet der Migration
und sie dürften nach Schengen dort nur
stichprobenartig kontrollieren man darf
an einer Schengen binnengrenze erse dann
tatsächlich kontrollieren wenn die
Grenze notifizierte spricht die ganz
Kontrollen bei der Europäischen Union
angemeldet und so wie es in Österreich
an österreichischen Grenze der Fall ist
jetzt setzen sich meine Kollegen zu
allem Überfluss dass sie da ihren
gesetzlichen Auftrag wahrnehmen auch
noch Vorwürfen aus sie würden Ration
Profiling betreiben weil sie Personen
kontrollieren die eben in dieses
Fahndungsraster passen weil die
gesetzliche Aufgabe der Bundespolizei
ist nun mal die Verhinderung der
unerlaubten Einreise und das finde ich
schlichtweg nur schäbig sie haben
tatsächlich ein Strategiepapier verfasst
das haben sie geschickt an unsere
Innenministerin Frau Faser reagiert hat
sie nicht nee bisher nicht sie wurde
aber schon mal darauf angesprochen auf
einem anderen Nachrichtensender glaube
ich und hat dort eine Antwort zugesagt
es wird höchste Eisenbahnen also das ist
schon einige Wochen her dass ich ihr
dieses Papier habe zugelassen das habe
ich auch nicht gemacht um sie zu ärgern
sondern schlichtweg um meinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jetzt endlich
auch mal eine Perspektive zu geben und
Entlastung zu schaffen was genau steht
denn drin was schlagen Sie vor wie kann
es besser werden ich schlag vor
Grenzkontrollen stationäre
Grenzkontrollen an der Grenze zur
Tschechischen Republik und nach Polen
denn darüber verlagert sich das momentan
derzeit einzuführen und am besten noch
gewahrsamszentren einzurichten gemeinsam
mit dem Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge damit wir dort eine
vernünftige Registrierung durchführen
können
Bundespolizei und BAMF und notfalls auch
wie Herr scheuer das sagte irgendwann
mal zu einem Punkt gelangen wo wir die
Migration schlichtweg stoppen müssen an
der deutschen Grenze
was macht man das naja und also
umsetzbar ist es in dem Moment wo dort
jemand steht der eben keinen schutzer
suchen äußert das ist ja das riesen
Problem die Menschen die dort ankommen
an der Grenze sind ja schon durch vier
oder fünf schenken Staaten gereist und
haben ja bewusst in den Schengen-Staaten
kein Asylantrag gestellt also der Trend
geht nach Deutschland man versucht nur
durchzukommen durch die durch die
anderen schenken starten und dann in
Deutschland letztendlich sein Asylantrag
zu stellen wer allerdings über einen
sicheren Drittstaat nach Deutschland
einreist der hat im Laufe des Verfahrens
kein Anrecht auf Asyl weil er ja eben
nicht mehr um sein Leben fürchten muss
wenn er einen einen anderen Staat schon
erreicht hat so und das ist wichtig für
die für die Asylverfahren und auch für
die Gerichte dass das dokumentiert wird
das schaffen wir aber nicht wenn ich
nicht probenkontrollen sie haben gerade
gesagt Deutschland ist so das Ziel
Nummer eins warum ist das ihrer Meinung
nach so weil die deutsche
Bundesregierung auch keine Gelegenheit
auslässt weitere pulfaktoren zu setzen
wenn wir uns das Gesetzesvorhaben des
neuen Zuwanderungsgesetzes angucken dann
wird er das Signal in die Welt gesendet
jemand der nach Deutschland kommt hier
Asyl beantragt auch wenn der Antrag nach
Jahren abgelehnt wurde rechtsstaatlich
abgelehnt wurde muss nur irgendwie fünf
Jahre durchhalten und bekommt dann
teilweise eine unbefristete
Aufenthaltserlaubnis für Deutschland das
sind die falschen Signale damit isoliert
Deutschland sich immer mehr in der
Europäischen Union und unsere
europäischen Nachbarn mit
EU-Außengrenzen die bedanken sich ja
förmlich schon dafür denn die haben das
Problem an der Ägäis im Mittelmeer oder
auch an Grenze zu Belarus das heißt
jetzt konkret was muss jetzt passieren
damit dieses Problem nicht noch größer
wird und wir irgendwann wieder da sitzen
wie 2015 und denken um Gottes ganze
wächst uns über den Kopf als nächstes
mal brauchen wir ein ganz ganz
konsequenten europäischen
außengrenzschutz die Grenzschutzagentur
Frontex muss dort noch stärker
eingesetzt werden an den Außengrenzen
und hier muss eigentlich schon die
unerlaubte Einreise nach Europa
verhindert werden wenn uns das nicht
gelingt dann muss es einem Nationalstaat
gestattet sein Grenzkontrollen
einzuführen um zu schauen wer dann wer
dann letztendlich ins Land kommt wir
müssen ja wissen wer kommt und wir
müssen wissen wo er her und das alles
können wir momentan mit den
stichprobenartigen Kontrollen an der
Grenze zur Tschechischen Republik und
nach Polen nicht gewährleisten das ist
einfach so nach Österreich an der Grenze
funktioniert die Bundespolizei hat auch
genug Personal eine stationäre Kontrolle
durchzuführen gar nicht das Thema das
der personalfresser sind die Stichproben
Kontrollen und das Verbringen der
Migranten nachher letztendlich in die
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung bzw in die
bearbeitungsstraßen das belastet unsere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mehr als würden
sie an einigen ausgewählten
Grenzübergängen stehen und dort eben die
Kontrollen durchführen harte Worte und
klare Forderungen heiko tega hat ganz
herzlichen Dank ansehen danke
[Musik]